[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
number 61 q and a segment
we stand ready and enabled with
the dog and the three cats in the
background well all right the three cats
as well
sure all right
we are going to start with four
questions from
episode
episode 60. wow i didn't okay i think
and um and then move on to the discord
and uh we continue to have tech problems
okay i'm there
evolution doesn't care who is suffering
or who's inconvenienced it isn't
feminist or fascist it's a beautiful and
different tragedy
how can we better tell hard truths about
our past optimally
and kindly yeah
uh that's a good one i would say
really the hard part is getting people
to
sign up for the initial foray
that in general people
once they discover that there is power
in an evolutionary analysis and that it
comes
with the uh the cost
of uh it's a very odd thing going on
back there
um but once people discover that there's
power in the analysis
that actually changes the way they live
which i think is almost inevitable
if you run into a good analysis people
are pretty much up for it
and the problem is in advance of that
discovery
people very often have a sense of
what it is that they expect will arise
and they have an opinion on whether or
not that's good in other words
you know one of the things that's so
ironic about you know
attacks on science on the basis of
uh the fact that there has been uh
racism in science
or that there's the perception that it
is hostile to one sex or the other um
is the net analysis is just so absurd
right yeah um the liberation that comes
from
the knowledge is vast and even if there
are elements of
what's there that you don't love it's
it's not the bulk of it
yeah i think that's good
that's a good answer all right we'll
leave it there
um which colleges might you advise your
sons to attend if they wanted a liberal
education
unconstrained by critical theory how
might you advise them to communicate
with those
thus constrained well i think this is a
good time
to talk about cryogenics and the
possibility that you may want to put
your children into cold storage
until we have generated a new academy
that doesn't
suck quite so much um
is that the wrong answer because that's
certainly so i don't i like the question
i obviously resurrected it from last
week but i don't have an answer
uh you know until two years ago or so i
was saying university of chicago it's
the it's the first it's standing strong
etc but um there's plenty to indicate
that
chicago itself is uh cracking from
within
in many regards um
yeah i do i do not have a good answer at
this point
uh the truly experimental colleges um
are likely to be just as royal by this
evergreen was one of them
yep and the
you know i think unfortunately the sort
of the state schools like the ag schools
and such
or the schools that were originally
land-grant colleges
are like everywhere
the science departments are going to
fall last and maybe the art
departments as well but the people being
hired
out of phd programs in
many of the social sciences and
humanities at this point those fields
are
so captured so corrupted that i don't
know
how you would hire faculty that
don't have this this virus in them so
you know you if if you know
what field you're interested in studying
and frankly i don't think it's a great
idea to know at 18 to be certain that
you really know what it is that you want
to be studying you should be
trying to be a generalist at that point
but if you really have a sense of like i
want to do
you know architecture or literature or
chemistry or whatever it is
um potentially looking sorry i mean this
is like the opposite device i would have
given 10 20 years ago but
looking for a department with older
faculty
faculty who may have been
may have at least gotten through their
own academic training
before this was quite so pervasive
might be one one approach but that
doesn't that doesn't address the fact
that administrators
um i did some research a couple years
ago it's published on
uh as a piece called on college
presidents
in which i looked at the the
demographics of college presidents
from a survey that's been sent out since
the 70s every six to 10 years or so
and the the academic fields
to which college presidents belong has
been skewing more and more towards
exactly these fields that are more and
more woke
and that's more true unfortunately the
less
elite the institution is and so the r1s
the you know the big research granting
universities especially the ones whose
names everyone knows
are more likely to have someone at the
helm who
you know might be a scientist and the
community colleges are more likely to
have people frankly who
got their degrees their higher degrees
their terminal degrees from ed schools
and
schools of ed are well captured
yeah i mean i think in some sense this
battle is over
and um the
the trajectory is very clear there's
nothing on the horizon
that solves this you know academia was
first to fall
it is the most deeply corrupted of
the institutions i think and ultimately
something will replace it or it will be
resurrected
but that's not on the horizon so
i think i would separate the question
into two things why are you going to
college
you're going to college to get a degree
because you need it that might change
to the extent of the people who come out
of colleges will be
lobotomized by the insanity that's going
on there
presumably employers will wise up and
stop requiring it and maybe even prefer
people who
didn't do that and then there's the
question of
what you will do to substitute for what
you would have learned
in college and the answer is that you
can do a lot about
right there's a ton you can do to get
the equivalent of a college education
without attending college or paying for
it so if we can separate those two
things
and correctly read the tea leaves that a
college education is not
going to be mandatory in a world where
what passes for college education
is subscribing to [ __ ] um
you know you can at least just limit
yourself to the second question which is
how am i going to end up
with um skills and insight that
i'm going to need and that you can do on
your own here so just to summarize your
point you there's a credentialing issue
and there's an actual skills and
knowledge issue
and they are
increasingly separable absolutely and
your tools for
sourcing your own uh knowledge insight
and skills are better than ever
right the number of things people will
teach you on youtube is incredible if
you can figure out how to
sort the wheat from the chaff the next
question is related would you consider
off would you
consider offering online courses with
zoom lectures syllabus writing
assignments etc i believe many would pay
market tuition
so we've thought about something like
this in the past and it's still
you know it's still a possibility uh
it's not an active project at the moment
but but we have thought about
uh we've certainly thought about
actually doing um
field trips extended field trips that
include curriculum in advance and
yeah yeah i think field trips would be
the most natural for us the most
fun and interesting um but from the
point of view of offering something that
uh you know college 2.0 um there is that
that idea is definitely live even though
the project is at the moment
not so can we promise if we do decide to
do field trips that no one has to eat
macaw
um you know it depends if things go
really wrong
yeah no problems are off yeah sure all
bets are off but we'll do everything we
can
i mean macaw is well above cannibalism
true yeah
yeah yeah and we won't er no none of the
paying customers will be macad so we'll
keep that line
really bright yeah i gotta say i think
that that
uh that pattern will carry over from the
past into the future almost no matter
what
true uh final comment from lap from
episode 60 regrow a pair yep i'd buy a
dark horse podcast shirt with that
printed on it
cool we'll put it on our list of uh
of new merchandise to produce we're
shooting for at least one new thing a
month so no it's funny because before
you mentioned
regrow up here i had a plan for a a
a graphic for grow a pair
which was going to be i don't mind
telling you hilarious
but regrow up here i think may have
jumped the queue and maybe a higher
priority
yeah i think it is okay from the discord
this week
we have why are there certain words that
are deemed socially inappropriate
what function do they have unlike taboos
which have practical uses such as don't
drink from the sacred fountain
also known as don't get eaten by
alligators
um well you know that i guess
my guess is it's not one category my
guess is there's certain things
that are just bad for us and therefore
um you can put off limits
um permanently and then there are other
things that are on reserve if you take
my
grandfather's suggestion that you
shouldn't abuse
profanity because someday you'll need
those words um
you know that basically says you don't
want to spend the value frivolously yeah
so that's that's sort of what i came up
with too that there are at least two
categories do you think that's it or do
you think there might be more
categories of we've called these swear
words
um and you should hold them in reserve
so that when you use them it's clear
that you are
putting emphasis on what you're saying
uh and
then you know epithets uh that really it
serves
no one but the narrowest tribal
interests of
you um to use and and there
there should be taboos because they're
just nasty to use
yeah um yeah i think generally it's
gonna look like that but what i would
say the interesting
biological thing is the fact of
tourette's syndrome
and its tendency to bring forth
um things that should not be said in a
particular context
does suggest that the context
is real and non-arbitrary right the idea
that the mind has
a category you know and i i think this
is sort of generally true
that um you know i always made a point
in
teaching college in not changing the way
i spoke
in class versus outside i think
it's an issue i don't think it is
inherently hypocritical to have two
different ways that you speak but for me
it was sort of necessary yeah um and you
know i also
don't restrict what i say around the
kids you know
uh so to the extent that there's a
certain level of cursing the kids hear
it
um and i don't think that's normal but i
do think
um anyway the recognition that there's
academy
there's no chance of there being a
discovery and they're like oh my god
you're or i am we we both do this you're
this other person in this other life you
have a different life
and you know i your child or i your
student didn't know that you had this
other life
and now that makes me question maybe all
these other things that i thought were
true about you and like you know like
you said there's not
there can be reasons to have these
different venues in which you have
different personas
um but it does it does allow
it opens the door to the possibility for
deceit in a way that if you are simply
um a continuous being with a way of
being in the world um if you start being
inconsistent with yourself it's
immediately apparent to you and everyone
around you
yeah i think the problem is there's a
slippery slope there somewhere
yeah and um you know dick alexander
my phd advisor used to make the point in
fact he made it in writing
somewhere i can't remember where exactly
but um
he makes the point that even you know
there's all sorts of
behavior you know right down to the
super mundane that is in that is
deceptive
right i remember he used the example of
a breath mint
right that you are you know disguising
how you actually smell
you know so anyway i wonder if that's in
biology of moral systems maybe
i can't remember i can't remember where
it is but um but in any case
the point is i don't think anybody you
know
it's not like you're really fooling
anybody you know for one thing a breath
mint smells like a breath mint so
it's you know it's pretty
straightforward right and uh
so that's not dangerous and then there's
a point at which you're two totally
different people
and that is dangerous and then there's
everything in between where there's some
slider and
so for some of us it's like well you
know what i actually don't want to
play the game of what's in the middle
because that has a cost and i can do the
other thing in the context that i live
in
but there's certainly roles that you can
play in life where you just can't do
that
yeah right no and i mean this boy this
this has been explored so beautifully in
literature and
by so many people but the one that comes
to mind right away is the
the picture of dorian gray you know
having the very different
visions that one of which cannot be
revealed to the world
lest the facade of both of them fall
apart yep
all right first question from this last
hour
alpha fold two near-term danger is
treating it as an oracle not a model
with assumptions
prion diseases show folding environment
effects folding
environment not input to alpha fold two
hidden assumption what other assumptions
comments so that was written in uh
without as many of the filler words as i
might have hoped for yeah um
i sort of i sort of get the question um
i agree
that you know protein folding holds
um potential hazards
you know prion disease now it turns out
prions have a whole
non-pathogenic uh landscape there's a
whole lot of interesting epigenetics on
protein folding that i have not
gone back into but was researching a lot
and we were doing some of our work
with being human six or seven years ago
whenever it was
um just super fascinating what the
environment produces
what the environment can produce with
regard to sort of a latent genetic
predisposition
yeah yes so the questionnaire here i
don't know exactly what they're getting
at but it sort of sounds to me like
the environment in which the protein
will fold
uh is an assumption of the model that
predicts in what way it will fold
yeah and it is too easy to say and in
fact much of what
what we and others said was basically as
if that wasn't true
that there's some way the protein will
fold which of course can't be
the case because uh temperature and ph
adjust protein folding in a way you know
why do we
manage our temperature and ph so
narrowly it's because your enzymes
don't function when they denature and so
the assumptions are
fundamental so i don't know what the
particular hazard the questioner is
after
here might be but yes there is an
assumption of
the folding environment built into the
prediction
yeah what you said just had me thinking
about frog eggs
of course of course well i mean i
actually had forgotten
i had not yes temperature narrow
temperature range because proteins
denature
at temperatures even just a little bit
elevated above their optimal range and i
sort of didn't have ph in that same
category
and i'm reminded of one of my really
surprising findings from my dissertation
research that was not in the realm of
behavior and sexual selection and
territoriality which is what i was most
interested in
but the more strictly ecological work
that i did where i was trying to figure
out
what the biotic mostly into some degree
abiotic parameters of these
like these little wells that the frogs
were reproducing in
um had like how were the wells that they
preferred and that they successfully
raised offspring and different from
the wells that were in the forest that
were unused by these frogs and
one of the things i found was that the
ph of the preferred
wells uh was much lower much more acidic
but like
seriously like three like insane
and i did this over a couple seasons
with a couple of different ph meters and
i had ph strips too so this wasn't just
like a calibration problem on my on my
tech
um this is this this struck me as
nearly impossible and you know frog eggs
are these are not
amniotes they don't have all the layers
of protection that we
mammals and birds and other reptiles
have
so uh just just shocking that these
that these developing frog embryos could
withstand and indeed
their parents preferred to lay them in
water that was such a low ph
well i think it makes good sense it's
you know a little hard to imagine how it
evolved
but well niche partitioning makes sense
but that low struck me as surprising
no i think it's going to be a little bit
like the logic of the ph of the stomach
right there's a lot of things that would
like to parasitize you
but there are very few things that
you're going to encounter out here in
the world
where the ph is neutral that can survive
being put through the incredibly low ph
of the stomach and so the point is it's
an extremophile thing
things can evolve to live in extremes
but the chances that you encounter them
in places that aren't extreme is low
so if you can have an extreme
environment it's a safer environment
so if you imagine this very high or low
ph
well yeah sitting in a world of path
potentially pathogenic things
the point is almost all of them will
fail immediately upon hitting that water
right and indeed as you know i
discovered
one mantela specific egg parasite
um that i had no idea what it was i
finally collected a bunch and you know
took them back home and
um turns out to have been cream fly
larva so noah nothing adult
predated these things um other species
of frogs that also had paternal care
that were
um depositing into the same environment
might um they weren't cannibalistic when
given the opportun
opportunity but it was the crane fly
larva that were most
the most rabid predators of of these
frogs and um the prediction may be a
prediction there would be
the cranfly adults upon laying the eggs
um needed to avoid um the water that it
would have that it would have been
maybe dangerous for them because they
live in a non-highly acidic world the
green flies
well at the very least i would predict
that the
crane flies themselves are
obligated to very
low ph uh wells and so they are forced
to be specialists
um by that environment because otherwise
it would be hard for them to have their
own enzymes and things that were
tolerant to it but not
requiring right but i'm talking about
the adults versus that yeah
the question is the adult laying the
eggs in the water
of the crane flies you know could just
contact it briefly which wouldn't
necessarily be that dangerous
although i mean the the adult frogs were
hanging out in the water
yep so i mean they were doing something
remarkable
well they may you know the obvious way
to deal with it would be to produce
a base on the surface of the skin that
would neutralize the acid
just create a little a little wetsuit
around yourself yeah a little
mucilaginous yeah wetsuit yeah something
like that
cool okay recent academic articles say
that the biggest threat facing humanity
is the population cliff
the worldwide birth rate is plummeting
and most likely to continue in that
direction
what is your opinion on that keep up the
good work in 2021
well you ain't gonna like this because
it's not a complete answer but
um here's the thing we've got too many
goddamn people
living simultaneously and i think we are
those of you who are long-term followers
of the podcast
will have heard me say many times that
we are in some sense morally obligated
to see just how many people we can give
the gift
of a liberated human life but
the key to that is reducing the number
of people
on the planet to some equilibrium number
that
we that is sustainable in the literal
sense where
it could go on indefinitely and so that
does not mean we are not headed for
disaster because we are
facing a reducing birth rate i mean the
population of the planet is still
growing so it's hard for me to see that
this is a danger
yet but to the extent that it might
reverse
um well some some weird countries
are experiencing population declines
right like italy and japan
yeah um so am i saying that it's just
safe and you know we should not worry
about it no it could cause catastrophe
and it could cause a lot of things but
long term
we need to be looking to backing the
human population away from carrying
capacity
and making life sustainable and the
thing is
i learned this actually one of those
things i learned in high school
that in fact the reduction
in population in europe after the plague
created the equivalent of a burst of
wealth right because effectively you had
people
living very densely
and that reducing the population
basically left more for everybody so
in these conversations we should all be
of the mindset that effectively we get
richer when there are a few of us here
fewer of us here simultaneously and if
that is the key to making us able
to have more people in sequence then
everybody wins
yeah i mean we we do have a couple of
different kinds of demographic problems
though
uh which is to say that the weird
countries are aging
so we're going to have an older
mostly post-work age group
that requires a lot of resources and
a relatively smaller cohort of people
who are still working and contributing
to the economy
and then in the developing world the
demographics are
almost the opposite where you've got a
whole lot of people
who are very much younger who will all
come of age around the same time
and you know if if those people
are uh are healthy and
and smart enough to be educable even if
they
weren't um as as youth because of the
conditions in which they grew up
um then dispersing the population across
across the globe is not it's not
inherently
disastrous and could address some of the
problem i
i haven't really spent much time with
this argument i know of it this idea of
the population cliff
i find it um
hard to believe but i'd want to spend
more time with it before i
dismissed it entirely i think the
problem is it just simply accepts
certain things as assumptions of the
future rather than leaves them
flexible to being reimagined and you
know
we cannot let the assumptions of the
president force us to keep playing this
game until we exterminate ourselves
because that's what's coming right if we
keep playing it this way
right universities are laying off many
professors due to declining enrollment
largely from covid and mainly adjuncts
how won't we make use of this newly
liberated intellectual resource
also mary ninth day of christmas oh just
to that last point um
as per your uh suggestion at the
beginning of live stream 60 that you
weren't sure if you were allowed to say
merry christmas still
we heard from a number of people who
said that the 25th of christmas is in
fact the first of the 12 days of
christmas and so
we were then and still are firmly within
christmas
now this is i i'm going to indict myself
permanently
in the eyes of many in our audience but
i have always imagined that the 12 days
of christmas was a myth pretty much
relegated to that song and didn't have
any deeper meaning than that am i
wrong yes the 12 days of christmas a
real thing yes
i don't know much more than that but um
there are active persistent traditions
which uh which celebrate the 12 days
that begin on the 25th and end on
i guess it's the sixth of january so
i had always and there are there are
words i think in latin for this that i
have forgotten but i'm sure are already
popping up in the chat
i had assumed that what had happened was
that so the christmas got
to put near the solstice because we
needed a
celebration holiday um
there are those two who argue that
actually no this really was uh jesus
birthday but
yeah i i have not seen a compelling
argument to that uh to that effect
so okay solstice holiday you kind of
fuse it with the
you know the birth of jesus and all of
this and then
you know modern times and the jews are
feeling like hey well
you know that's not our holiday and so
they
boost the maccabees story to be a a time
of celebration and gift-giving
you think it's christian one up
oxmanship well i was going to say arms
race but
uh but yeah i thought so but one day
eight days twelve days
something like that yeah your move jews
that sort of thing something like that
yeah okay that's not what's going on no
okay why are there 12 days
do we know i yes we do but we don't oh
we in this room yes us and whatever cats
don't yeah i'm sure the cats don't know
so
um to the actual question um how might
we make use of this newly liberated
intellectual resource that newly
liberated intellectual resource being
the laying off of many professors
i wish i were more certain that it was a
intellectual resource
um and that may sound cruel and
harsh but i've met a lot of faculty
and most of them should not be educating
your children or
claiming to do research and that's
maybe unfortunately true across all
manner of fields i know what
faculty sound and look and act like
better than
most fields but boy is it hard to be
impressed with the category as a whole
after spending time with a lot of
faculty
it's funny your first sentence i had
formulated
almost the identical sentence to gently
point to the fact that possibly this was
not a massive
intellectual resource waiting to be
tapped um
so presumably there are some
ver presumably there are some very good
people who now find themselves who were
stuck in
adjunct land you know who were driving
between four different colleges making
crap money um teaching way more students
they could ever possibly develop
relationships with
and you know being basically beaten down
by an academic system
uh that is not um that is not
interested in actually preserving the
intellectual rigor and honesty of
of most good people presumably some of
those people now find themselves
liberated by not even having um
that work what what if anything
might be done at a societal level uh to
to to help society and to um
have them send their good good work into
production yeah i agree i agree with
this um
in the group of people who have been
laid off will be
some very good 100 people um
it won't be a large percentage okay but
it'll be enough i was my 100
was agreeing with you 100 yes yeah oh
yeah
i had no doubt yes there was zero
ambiguity there yeah um
what i would say is that there's
something waiting to be
born or maybe it's not quite maybe it's
already there but
the number of
people who will
go to youtube or other places for
valuable content is large
and to the extent you know i i kind of
would love to see meritocracy break out
and you know i don't you know i don't
know where presumably those people who
don't really know anything and have been
laid off from their university jobs
um should go do something else but uh to
the extent that the
um the market might provide a mechanism
for
people who actually were insightful to
find an audience
uh more power to them and you know one
can imagine communities of such people
gathering and who knows maybe that's
where the reboot for the
academy comes from yeah cool
okay um regarding a question from last
time
offspring might solve the immortality
problem for a lineage but not for an
individual consciousness which you
obviously care about
else why cure disease when you could
just have kids the reproduction rate
tends to go down as longevity increases
and since we can't rely on an afterlife
it seems rational to extend our own
lives as long as possible
dementia notwithstanding yep i hear you
on the one hand it does solve the
consciousness problem because
what you know goes out of date two and
so
the portion of your consciousness that
actually
is valuable going forward gets edited
down
and presumably i think this is frankly
built into the grief process when
you lose somebody you do forget all
sorts of trivia
about them and you retain the stuff
that's really deep
and that that editing process is is
positive um that the problem it doesn't
solve
is the crisis for the individual who
feels
the threat of loss of everything they
know
and you know one of the
deep ironies or troubling facts about
death is that there's nothing to it
right it just you know will there be
relief from whatever you're suffering
from
no there'll be no relief there'll be
nothing right
and um well oh i don't
you won't be in pain you won't be in
pain but you won't
be generally the connotation pain
because you won't be right
the connotation of not being in pain
though
is the experience of not being in pain
it's not great right
because you won't not be in pain either
right i mean it is equally true
philosophically to say that you are only
in pain
right here and that is an infinitesimal
part of the universe the number of
places that you are simultaneously not
in pain
is indefinitely large and so that isn't
comforting to you either is it
right so if only i could get one of
those other places right
and as soon as you got there you'd bring
your pain with you so anyway
uh the point is yeah there's something
very troubling to a mind that is built
to be confused about the importance of
its
perception yeah right about well
that can't just come to an end can it
and you know
yes it can and you know i used to
when i used to get into these arguments
and college dorm rooms and stuff
you know i would say when you were
yourself in college what
you mean when you were yourself and i
was not with your own students right
yeah right um but i you know i'd say
look we know what happens
after death we know where you're going
you're going exactly where you were
before you were born
and you know the point is
you were there indefinitely and then you
were briefly here and then you will go
back there indefinitely
or infinitely um
so before you were uh fertilized perhaps
right not before you were born right
exactly
um so anyway the point is i think this
is just a problem
that doesn't need a solution it is its
own solution
and um does it make sense to stick
around as long as possible hell yeah
it's a whole sea of not being with a
brief intermission of being like why not
get the most out of that thing
because that's all you're going to get
it's the intermission right believe it
or not i actually enjoy living with this
guy
oh boy yeah well you know i i don't know
i think
you know it it is the cosmic joke and as
soon as you're in on it things get
better
okay um we're gonna read a few more from
this and then move to the next hour our
culture is biased against introverts
given the talk of diversity and
inclusion these days why has
introversion not emerged as a protected
class
should we establish a grievance movement
to correct this hell yeah
of course we should you go first
right now i mean i've i have not used
introversion as
as the one but i have used handedness
like
okay there's ten percent consistent
across cultures
of us who are left-handed and um because
we're a distinct minority the world
you know the world of tools is largely
built for right-handers
and um and you know anything that has
the potential to have asymmetry in it
along a line of access
is mostly built for right-handers and
you know we need to be talking about
handedness bias
well no we don't and you know there are
there
are privileges and advantages and
disadvantages everywhere you look so
i i appreciate the question as a
fellow introvert but yeah anything to
add
um not really i mean the irony of us
both being pretty
severely introverted and yet here we are
here we are speaking into a
series of cameras in front of thousands
of people so
you know it is what it is um it's it's
it's a disadvantage
but it can be overcome yeah
uh biden and atf uh alcohol to back on
firearms right
biden and atf are alarming gun owners
right now
it seems like a bad time to be
antagonizing them is this another case
that the left causing the very
thing civil war is similar that they
hope to stop
i don't know what this is in reference
to i don't even know i don't know what
biden or the atf are doing um
probably i wish they'd stop but i don't
know what they're doing so
uh yeah i have no idea and i don't
really want to comment
i would say you know the truth is
it is obvious and i think every
reasonable person would agree
that we need regulation of
arms i mean you can't have a nuclear
weapon i'm sorry no matter how much you
want it no matter how much it seems to
be
yeah included under the second amendment
you can't have it right um
on the other hand um you know
i think the idea that firearms are
so prominent in our constitutional
framework has a lot to do with the hedge
against tyranny that we don't talk
enough about right and
on the third hand good the
the third hand we have a brand new set
of threats for which we have no
conceivable mechanism
of self-defense right we've got this
whole uh
ai slaughter bot
uh future headed our way that's a new
word
uh nope it's not i'm sure it's not but i
don't like it
no i don't like it either and the people
who invented it don't like it
one bit and they are ai researchers so
anyway
uh we are in the post-modern future in
which
self-defense has become an incoherent
concept and
we're going to have to rethink these
things but the idea that there's any
simple answer like you're entitled to
have whatever arms you want
that can't be right you can't have any
arms that can't be
yeah um so what is the answer yeah
um regret comes from living
wait oh i skipped one
uh brett and heather the simple uh the
sympathetic intelligence that
characterizes your relationship
is as rare as it is inspiring here's
some bucks for the smart rapport fund
thank you nice thank you next question
regret comes from living in a dark past
fear from living in a dark future
courage from living in the present the
way to find courage is to be in the
moment and deal with things as they are
not as they were or might be you know
that is
interestingly consistent i believe with
the
the theme the first against the wall
club
the idea is what imprisons you in the
present
is fear of what might be in the future
what happens if i actually say what's
true rather than what
this mob wants me to say right and
really the point i think i didn't say it
very clearly at the beginning of the
podcast
is make your peace with it now
right make your peace with it up front
not in the moment when you're faced with
that mob
because yeah then you will cower and if
you make your piece with it up front and
you just say look
okay i get it there's something
frightening there's a threat it's real
but i'm not going to live i'm not going
to be governed by that threat
then you will behave differently and my
guess is
you'll be glad for it and you will
navigate better because
the last thing you want is your fears
governing you in that moment you will
navigate very poorly if you do it that
way yeah
is unconscious bias unscientific
in my opinion bias has to be conscious a
conscious discernment creates a pattern
we recall and recognize that consciously
built pattern of biases from our
subconscious
how can bias be unconscious how compass
okay this confuses me me too my feeling
is um
the most persistent bias will be
unconscious
yes and in fact you know what we don't
say
is that most biases are accurate
and serve you right and the point is
when we say
bias we are invoking it for a category
that is understood to be negative but
basically you your conscious experience
of the world
is built on heuristics like i'm biased
towards not going outside in current
conditions without a raincoat or an
umbrella
yeah or more fundamentally i am biased
towards
paying attention to the edges of objects
and not their middles
right and the point is when navigating a
space right as you're walking around
knowing where the edges are allows you
to navigate quickly and effectively
whereas you know
mulling over the surface detail wouldn't
and so anyway you are
nothing but biases and those biases are
nothing but good for you except in very
rare circumstances which is why
there's such fascination with things
like and exactly most of those biases
don't come to consciousness they just
exist and you navigate based on right
they don't come to consciousness because
they work so goddamn well right
and you know it's the occasional optical
illusion
that reveals that you are wired in this
way something that pivots just between
two interpretations so your mind flips
back and forth reveals that you're a
heuristic machine
but right anyway so the point is okay
your heuristic machine
and then you find that certain biases
you know stereotypes for example are
disallowed the penalty for them goes up
they may be inaccurate or they may be
accurate and
the problem is how do you convince a
heuristic machine to give up a given
heuristic
and sometimes that must be the case but
i think the point is this is so much the
exception
the rule is heuristics which are biases
and that means
most of them are unconscious and then
you can promote one to consciousness
like for example
if there's a particular set of
heuristics that obscures something that
you now need to focus on
right if you started studying um why am
i forgetting the name of the um
leaf-tailed gecko you're a plato you're
a platus
right europlatus is a lizard that sticks
to the
surfaces of tree trunks in such a way
that it's almost impossible to see and
if you look it up on the internet
you will see pictures and you'll think
that's impressive but it's nothing the
camera actually reveals these things
whereas the eye
misses them routinely gorgeous malagasy
gecko
known in the pet trade so if people are
portrayed people they'll know europlatus
but the point is you can learn to find
them but in general you learn to find
them by taking the thing
which you profit from every time you
walk by a tree and don't
focus on the details of its bark right
that
you can start focusing on the details of
its bark and you can look for these
animals and if you started studying them
it would be like oh i've got to find
those things everywhere they are so now
i'm going to focus on exactly the thing
that i've been productively ignoring for
my entire life
right so you can promote a bias to
consciousness
if you need to and that's very often
what we do but let's not mistake
bias for those things that we promote to
consciousness because they are negative
in some way
right bias is how the system works
cool how's the super chat alternative
app coming along
have you considered setting up streaming
through stream labs for donation
unlike super chat it does not take any
cut love you both
so we actually just talked with uh the
awesome
guy who's making the super chat
alternative um it's getting close
uh i don't know anything about stream
labs um just never heard of it there are
okay our producer also our eldest son
says it wouldn't work that great for
this and i quote but i'm not sure why
so um but yeah hopefully um i don't know
maybe within the month we'll be doing uh
our first trial
yep yep one more in this one and then we
will uh
uh we'll move to the next hour why did
some dinosaurs grow so big
what was different from the world today
was it climate co2 levels food supply
more fertile soil that made it favorable
for some of these amazing creatures to
reach such
enormous size
yeah well there's a question about why
be big at all
and so yeah um let's put this
we have we have giant vertebrates now
but they're in the water
yep they're where they're freed from
gravity yeah
exactly as soon as you come out on land
you've got a whole other set of
gravitational constraints
which the earliest tetrapods had to deal
with and you know we're
modifying all the sensory organs for
different indus refractive indices of
light versus water et cetera error
versus water
so here's the real question
and this is one of the reasons that i
argue that we have the definition of
fitness wrong
that are definitely evolutionary fitness
yeah by
synonymizing it with reproduction you
are effectively inviting the following
paradox
why would something like a bear
not choose to be a thousand creatures of
smaller size if it's got the resources
to be a bear
then why wouldn't it choose to increase
its fitness by being divided up more
and so i think the point is what we say
frequently is that
the meaning of evolutionary fitness is
about
persistence and one of the contributors
to persistence is population size
and so that's why reproduction shows up
at all
but it is not the only way and so in
some sense
a bear is better able to both
persist and to er to
put its descendants in a position to
persist
by being one coherent entity rather than
many
entities so the question then is why
did some dinosaurs like brontosaurus
make that calculation at an even bigger
scale
and uh i have no idea my guess is it has
to do
with the intensity of competition and
that basically
well and also the arms risk between
predator and prey
presumably an animal that big had very
low
risk this is this is my point that you
know a small brontosaurus
can get taken out by a comparable sized
um or you know group hunting uh
carnivorous dinosaur but at some point
you're just too
you're too big to fail
yes too big to fail indeed and you know
elephants
elephants are like those baby elephants
are vulnerable but uh right your
elephants are not
yeah so anyway yeah why the scale
difference i don't know there are some
things that were very large relative to
their counterparts in the present during
the
carboniferous yeah i think it was the
carboniferous that seems too long ago
but things like giant sloths which is
much more recent
yeah that's much more recent um no i'm
talking about things like giant
dragonflies
or and um like trilobites
some really big no not so much i'm not
sure i think that yeah let's stick with
dragonflies
yeah we'll stick to dragonflies giant
dragonflies hopefully in the
carboniferous and we'll hear from our
paleontological counterparts yeah i
don't think that's wrong i don't have
the periods in my head but also some
really big amphibians for instance
yep yep the dragonflies at least okay
we'll stick with dragonflies
i think uh we're about a heavily oxygen
enriched
environment and so this was a
downstream consequence of um
them breathing through their legs well
of the basically the production
of oxygen by photosynthesis and so that
you had this very
high oxygen period um
which i think results in fires that
result in the carboniferous
being wow am i going to say a bunch of
wrong things simultaneously and
hear hear from our critics but um but
anyway
yes so i don't think that that i don't
think anything like that is contributing
to
uh giant dinosaurs yeah i i
am unaware of anything like that either
yeah yeah
um so it's some other phenomenon like
yeah i mean there was like
you did have i think the toughest ocean
in the middle you know before the the
breakup of
um boy
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna screw it up too
i think you know asia and gondwana
hadn't even split you know pangaea and
split and you still had the tethys ocean
around which the
shallow shores of which had some of i
think the early dinosaurs but
i think it's going to be later than that
yeah um but anyway
all right we are making things up done
sabotaging our credibility with uh
loose paleo loose paleo that's not why
you come for close paleo
first question from this hour what if
any recessive traits
could the child of beauty and the beast
show
have given exactly no thought to beauty
and the beast yeah
i just i barely know i have seen
vignettes
well i mean it's a i did i had actually
forgotten that it was like a disney
thing
but it like it's it's a fairy tale from
long ago
i know i don't know i just i don't have
a question
well yeah what might be revealed that
you know what what
what might beauty and the beast actually
have in common that gets revealed when
brought into homologous um i mean the
answer is
anything because recessive i mean
so i i just don't understand how you
would limit yeah
yeah it could be anything the question
yeah yeah there could be almost anything
lurking
yeah um two-part
question could agriculture have emerged
in the tropics
and two is there a parallel to be drawn
between how humans competing mainly
against their environment versus against
other humans
may have led to different cultures and
innovations in temperate versus tropical
zones
okay with regard to the first one
agriculture did emerge in the tropics
agriculture
um convergently we humans convergently
evolved agriculture several times
yes once in the fertile crescent of
mesopotamia which is the story that most
of us are most familiar with
but also at least it seems twice
in china one of which is getting to the
sub-tropical zone in the south and i
can't remember
i'd have to remind myself of what the
main crops were it was like
it was rice i think in the south and it
was one of the great one of the other
grains
in the north um but you have
certainly two maybe three evolutions of
agriculture in the new world as well
and um often when people say tropics
they are implying lowland tropics
um but the andes uh where the inca were
are the tropics even though it's higher
elevation and so
more of a a temperate seasonal regime
but the uh incans invented agriculture
and so too did the maya well actually
the incans will have inherited um
no i don't think i think the evidence is
not that they inherited it actually
um but probably um probably the
maya and the aztec told jacqueline
michael of this is one evolution
so it's very hard to tell you have a
bunch of different habitats with
different
populations in them which could all be
one evolution by virtue of the fact that
you wouldn't have evidence of one person
transmitting the idea no of course not
one person but if if memory serves and
i'm not
i don't i can't pull this up precisely
and i don't know what paper it's going
to be in but
um if i remember correctly there's just
no evidence there's no archaeological
evidence
of any kind of agriculture in um
northern south america
that you have like um that you know
colombia
um and venezuela and sort of down the
west coast and then you get
um evidence among the inca but you have
tiwanaku to go west
in um
they are to the west of the andes
in northern south america
the first of the great temple building
cultures okay so
um anyway i think i think the inquiry is
going to be late in the story which
doesn't mean that they're not the same
population
that was um was in the andes
uh so this this would have been the
foothills of the andes and who knows
diwanaku may not be the first and they
may have
picked up agriculture from uh central
america
well that's what i'm saying there's
apparently no archaeological evidence
that
there is strong suggestion that there
were two
new world tropical evolutions of
agriculture at least okay
so whether or not the inca were the
first where they are that's that's not
that's beside the point here that um
somewhere andes-ish
and somewhere mesoamerica-ish were two
separate evolutions of agriculture it
seems
yep i still i don't see a way that
tiwanaku is not um
basil to the inca is that that i mean
i i don't know anything about the
tewanaku but that doesn't change the
the conclusion that i just laid out it
may you know it there may be something
else there but you haven't
said anything yet to suggest that
there's a reason to
throw over the two different evolutions
of agriculture in the near tropics i
don't think that i don't think
there is a reason to throw it over in
fact my guess is it's going to be more
than two because you also have
um lots of modern evidence that is
emerging
in the amazon itself right which is
because agriculture is so different in
that environment
it's liable to be a third which doesn't
mean that an individual didn't transmit
the information or a small number of
individuals didn't transmit the
information in a way that we'd have no
way of knowing
right um so how many evolutions is it
really yeah
so anyway the agriculture of emerging
the tropics it did
it did um it's not you know the ones
that we know of from the tropics
um and you know i think there's at least
i think there's at least one known
evolution in africa as well although i
know that
evidence far less well i know for sure
too in china
one mesopotamia to at least a new world
and i think i think there's more than
that but you know just
even that we have um with um
good evidence that it couldn't have been
communicated
separate evolutions including some in
the tropics i think there's
definitely an african one though i think
so too uh
i know i don't know i won't know the
example
um but anyway yeah involved evolved many
times and
you know at the very least we know that
the new world was completely independent
and we believe that the new world
tropics um
yeah were an origin point in the new
world
right at least one yeah because i mean
there is um
actually i'm not sure if there's any
north american pre-columbian
ag yeah there is mississippi valley
and the like so i know there's a lot of
there's there's there's
there's like selective harvesting but is
there
ag i believe so okay um also then maybe
the southwest
anyway is there a parallel to be drawn
between how humans competing mainly
against their environment
versus against other humans may have led
to different cultures and innovations in
temperate versus tropical zones
um well you know this this is a tough
question i don't know that tempered
versus tropical is what you want to do
certainly incan agriculture and mayan
agriculture
were radically different by virtue of
the highland
lowland distinction um so you know the
intense
terracing that the inca had to do
um and you know other things like um
uh what would you call it um
evaporating off water to get salt things
like this so
you know there are lots of distinctions
based on
what habitat one is doing their
agriculture in
um you know rice paddies not rice
paddies but uh
potato corn grown in terraces and all in
the
in the high andes and all so yeah
they're distinctions i don't know
what conclusion to draw about these
patterns and whether there's anything
consistent between
continents but yeah there are patterns
what can international relationships
know
start over what can international
relations learn
from evolutionary psychology i am a
master's student
tired of sociology theorists who say war
is a social construction
do you have uh book recommendations i
have only read
alexander's darwinism and human affairs
so far
hmm good one yeah very good um
i don't have a book recommendation
article recommendation that i'm going to
pull up
that may send you to more but you go
first i think
the the key insight is that between
you have the same process unfolding at
all scales
between lineages and nations tend to be
lineages they're not always
ours isn't but they do tend to be and so
the point is look
there are two fundamental bases for
collaboration one of them is genetic
and the other is effectively
reciprocity and to the extent that
nations
face the same questions as smaller
groups
it makes sense to bias the world in the
direction of reciprocity because the
other thing leads to
genocide and warfare and
collaboration because it's profitable is
exactly the opposite so we
um you know i don't know how much
more there is to say than that how this
unfolds is something that we don't have
a lot of
literature on because frankly everybody
is so damn
stubborn about admitting that this is
really the nature of
conflict between populations right
everybody i mean you know apparently
dawkins is doubling down on this
about his skepticism that there's
anything to say about uh you know
human relations of this nature and
frankly i think it's just a
fear of the part of the answer that's
obviously unpleasant but
the degree to which you know which do
you want do you want a model
that forces you to look at the ugliness
of
evolution and its drive to spread
one set of genetic spellings over
another
you know would you like to hide from
that and continue to suffer from it or
do you want to recognize it
and do away with it and if you want to
do away with it
i don't see how we're going to go around
understanding what it is and why it
happens and how you would have to
structure things to prevent it from
unfolding repeatedly so with regard to
recommendations
um there's an article uh by robert
sapolsky
uh who's terrific um that he that
published in the january february 2006
issue of foreign affairs
called a natural history of peace this
is something i used to include in the
course backs
from my animal behavior students quite
good
similarly um there was was it the i feel
like there was a jared diamond article
as well um that was quite um quite good
and sort of on topic but
um with regard to longer things
saposky's newest book i mean anything by
sapolsky i think is would be relevant
here but behave
is quite good and then also uh franz de
duval
i think it may be pronounced uh
d-e-w-a-a-l
um all of his stuff as well uh
and this you know again so sapolsky
mostly worked on uh
baboons to fall on on chimps
so it's not evo psych these these are um
these are people working
on our our close relatives not other
humans
primarily um devol's peacemaking among
primates
also might be a place that you could
find some
some good ways to respond to the social
constructionists in your midst
yep all right i can't find anything on
my computer at the moment
here we go oh my god
could city-state ruination be an evolved
dispersal strategy for ideology
in societies where there is free and
relatively convenient
travel and relocation
try that again could city or state
ruination
be an evolved dispersal strategy for
ideology
in societies where there is free and
relatively convenient travel and
relocation got it
yep cool um yes
in fact i have heard consternation in
certain circles about um
liberal do-gooderness um wrecking cities
as a result of well-intended
apocalyptically foolish policy
and then people being driven out people
of means who
were in a position to cause those
policies to be adopted moving to places
that aren't ruined
and then voting for the same thing so
anyway the question about whether or not
one calls out a strategy or whether it's
just an inadvertent pattern or could be
both in different contexts but yeah i
think the the thing that you're
arguing probably might exist does exist
at least it's a hazard
next question 90 of the women i know
have severe hormonal issues including me
do you think the cause is ltbcp
i don't know what that acronym stands
for i was trying to look it up i didn't
have time you didn't talk long enough
lt bcp environment diet chemicals etc
any one or several of them help um
for sure we are sick uh
as a sort of weird uh
again acronym western educated
industrialized rich democratic
population because we have messed with
our environment including our diet
and and certainly the air we breathe as
well um quite
a lot and there are um
there are estrogen mimics in our
plastics in our water supply
pesticides which is how it gets into our
water supply
if you are eating anything but the
freshest food that is as close to whole
as possible you're likely getting
some of these from from the packaging
or actually the ingredients of said food
the more shelf-stable food is
the more likely it is to cause
endocrinological disruption
i wish lt bcp i suspect is another sort
of
hormone disruptor thing or oh it's birth
control pill
um long-term birth control pills that's
what that's gonna stand for
um yes that too unfortunately
um yeah i would i would love to talk
about this
at length at some point actually um
as for help uh
long-term hormonal disruption is hard to
recover from especially if it started
when you were very young
but freeing yourself from as many of the
possible perturbers
of your evolved system as possible is
is the way to go and it's not
necessarily going to be comfortable and
it certainly won't be easy
and obviously you know long-term
hormonal birth control
is um simultaneously
a great freedom that has allowed
women to actually move into
intellectual and creative space in a way
that was very very difficult until
recently
and also um a problem for for both
individuals and society
both of those things are true um i was
on i was on
birth control pills for decades myself
um and at some point
um i realized and sort of with a start
went like oh my god
this this cannot be safe actually
uh and and went off them um
but yeah
[Music]
trying to get to uh a a
pre-industrial set of inputs
to your uh your diet and your exposures
as possible is um a good
first pass anything to add no
yeah a lot more to say yep
when you say we must win in reference to
the woke culture are you concerned that
the we win you lose mentality
contributes to the polarization
you know i've thought about this before
um and i actually um well actually you
i'm going to pull something up you start
talking
yeah i don't think so because
i don't think we have to win over any
individuals but yes
perspective wise these two things do not
coexist right either we're going to turn
the world upside down
over a postmodern view of how reality
functions or
we're going to establish a kind of
bedrock about how
we figure out what's true and how we
modify it to
improve our model and
you know reality is under attack by
people who have
um an agenda that requires them
to uproot our tools
i don't see any way yeah we could find
nicer language than winning but no we
have to win right reality has to win and
those who are obligated to it
are going to have to make that happen
now ideal way that that could happen
is we could persuade people and at some
point
we persuade enough people and those who
are
um attempting this will stop right
so i'm not arguing for something that is
the defeat of individuals but
um you know there's right and there's
wrong
and we we cannot surrender reality
to any of this nonsense yeah that's
right so um
i wrote a piece i can't share my screen
at the moment because of the problems
we're having here
um but on medium if you just search for
me on medium a piece that i published
november 2018
called grievance studies versus the
scientific method um
was formulated as a response to someone
who on
um i in responding to
james lindsay who many of you will know
as a friend of ours um
said one more major reveal we'll send
the authoritarian nonsense in higher ed
up in flames i hope you're right about
this
but the rhetoric is growing ever more
entrenched and people make up excuses
for the cases they can't explain
someone on twitter says to me why must
this be worded in conflict flames and
victory over an enemy
i ask in the spirit of inquiry so this
is that same this is exactly the same
question
and i began my response which is fairly
long here by saying word choice is
important
it sways people and so you're right to
wonder is it necessary to use language
that implies
uh competition in this case it is i say
it is there's real conflict here uh it
is not the scientists and other
practitioners
practitioners of enlightenment methods
and values who created the conflict
however
nor are we defending our privilege by
resisting the forces that are coming at
us
and then i provide lots of evidence of
the conflict is being created on the
other side and therefore um
to not to pretend that the conflict
isn't there or to roll over
and um you know and basically take an
entirely defensive stance is to
guarantee
um losing we didn't create the
competitive environment but here it is
and frankly
um defending truth reality science
enlightenment values is something i'm
perfectly happy to
if i have to you know get in the
trenches about
yep i think the last thing that i would
say in uh
in reflection here is that
those of us who must win this
it's winning it for everybody yeah the
people who are pushing this stuff
don't realize that they are creating a
unstable system that will collapse on
them and it will cause
starvation and warfare and probably
genocide
and so for their own good they need to
lose that's just the way it is
what are your thoughts on jordan
peterson saying that evolution is a
conservative force
for example uh the same snake circuitry
fuses up when in danger
it is largely a conservative force but
it does i mean you know
it's the perfect balance between these
two forces right it preserves that which
works and it innovates
where something is possible it's not
going to innovate something that already
exists
why why would any any functional system
so yeah it's not going to innovate so
it'll innovate something that exists
over there and innovated over here but
yeah
um but i think the point is the wisdom
is in recognizing the balance between
these two forces
right and to the extent that something
is near perfect you will find
evolution not changing it and to the
extent that something is really
sub-optimal you'll find
lots of change and what more could you
ask for
yeah it's a really effective system yeah
why did introversion and extroversion
emerge as traits to be selected for
are there any advantages you've noticed
in today's landscape that are shared by
introverts
so this is another topic that i feel
like we could spend you know probably a
whole episode on um
you and i have talked privately before
about thinking that actually
these these categories as much as we
immediately recognize them
um aren't aren't really granular enough
that like you and i are actually using
really different kinds of introverts
and the majority of the world being
extroverted i'm sure
is obscuring a whole lot of diversity of
ways that people are extroverted as well
and um
one thing that seems true
across the introverts i know and m
is that the desire for introversion well
two things
um is not um
does not mean that you don't like being
around people yeah right
that um but that you also both crave and
really need
time alone in order to you know
re-energize in order to do the work that
you want to do
and then it's that time alone uh where
you tend to innovate often
and you know like we can we can do it
we can effectively kind of be alone
together well
um but it's still not the same thing as
being entirely alone
and that um i suspect that that
i don't know how tightly but to some
loosely to tightly we'll map on to
introversion extroversion
is sort of being um a unit tasker versus
a multi-tasker and there is of course
lots of new research suggesting that
lots of people think they're
multitaskers and are actually not very
effective at it
and that you know being driven to be
around other people all the time may
mean that really you know
your talent your skill is in the energy
of the people and
and getting new people together and all
of this
if if your talent is in bringing
innovation into the world there is a
good chance that even if you're not
comfortable with it that you're going to
need some time without the other
influences
to you know get them out of your head
and just focus
and so this sort of introversion and
unit asking
sort of recognition of the need for unit
tasking i think will will map
somewhat as character traits um
i agree with that i'm also not sure how
ancient
any of this is yeah i think that there's
something about modernity that has freed
us
to buy us in the direction of some level
of sociality
um that happens to work for whatever
reason but you know i
i don't i don't think a hunter-gatherer
i don't think i don't think this
distinction would occur to a hundred
people couldn't
right you you know the people that you
know you encounter them as regularly as
you encounter them
i mean i expect there would be variation
in in terms of like oh
she she likes to spend more time alone
than the rest of us you know that's a
little odd
like i i expect that that kind of
variation would exist
um but it wouldn't be so discreet yeah i
don't i don't think it'd be
it wouldn't be like this and so anyway
there's a question about whether
something that would have some natural
variation has been amplified
into a you know population level
distinction
um just because we can choose and it
doesn't have profound implications
necessarily on
uh how we function in the world because
so much of the world has been
offloaded to the market or whatever yeah
um but anyway
so uh and also these things it seems to
me very
flexible right i i was certainly a shy
kid and uh i've gone through
period you know just the simple fact of
what has happened to our life since
2017 has made me much more extroverted
just by you know
forcing me into lots and lots of social
contact
yeah um so anyway i'm not sure what it
is or what it means
yeah no there's i mean there's more to
be said there but um
maybe maybe we'll move on we have been
joined by our
eldest carnivorous member
erin 13 minutes okay well we have we got
a lot of questions this week
um we're not going to get through nearly
all of them
let me quickly scroll down and pick
three more
shall we um
i don't know enough about the next one
okay so um
[Music]
i'm a transplant recipient working with
physicians
on restructuring the medical model by
implementation of self-awareness as a
means to health care versus sick
care any suggestions on facing the
shadows
i'm not sure i know what that means i
don't know what that means either
unfortunately the next several
uh i think there's something really deep
here but i'm not sure
um
uh what they mean necessarily so um
you know what i'm gonna do is go back to
a few from the previous hour and then
i'll pick a bunch
a few of these up for next time ones
that i already knew um
were good psychedelic therapy will
likely be legal and widespread pretty
soon
given the mystical components of the
experience it seems there will be some
amount of religious backlash
what are some ways we can mitigate this
clash
well i actually wonder if um
progressive liberal folk won't actually
adopt some of this stuff i doubt some of
what stuff
psychedelic stuff i mean they're
spearheading it
are we talking about something different
um
if you won't find churches employing
mushrooms
is there something i don't know about
maybe i just missed what you said you
want to say what you what your claim was
i'm wondering if
instead of a backlash from religious
people against
psychedelics if there will not be a
fusion
of the two things okay i thought you
said the the left and the woke would
adopt the psychedelics no
okay so no so anyway i
i don't know but certainly in
conservative circles there will be
lots of fear and consternation and
frankly i'm not sure that there isn't
reason for it because
these are tremendously powerful
chemicals
and in the context in the proper context
they can be very
useful in upgrading mental architecture
as michael pollan points out
in a haphazard frivolous recreational
context they can be destructive
and i don't really trust
civilization to do this well i don't
know that i trusted to do
the medical part of this well especially
in light of the way the
medical apparatus demonized this stuff
for the longest time
as if it was inherently destructive and
the idea of oh now it's medical
right um strikes me as you know well
you botched this you're last in line
from the perspective
of rationally figuring out how to employ
this
um so i don't want to see it medicalized
and i fear that that's
where we're headed on the other hand you
know the
the folks who said that marijuana
legalization for medical purposes was a
gateway
to uh full legalization were right
and i'm not sure what to make of what
the net effect was as we've talked about
before
i think uh legal pot is
just fine in the ancestral form but in
the very strong form that it exists now
um ironically the concerns about
marijuana which were initially
fabricated nonsense are now much more
realistic
yeah we let market forces change the
plant and then we legalized it
and now it's a totally different drug
from what it was and it actually does
um have associations with psychosis and
such yeah right
which which it did not i would love to
see a
an enlightened non-medical
approach to psychedelics which can
include
therapeutic value but well and also i
mean to to the question about
um you know mitigating the clash between
psychedelic therapy
and and the religious you know as
as a way as a way to find god you know
as a way to find your spiritual self
and uh dissolve ego and you know
be your best self this these are some of
the ways
that uh you know the shamanistic
approaches to psychedelics
are used of course in other contexts and
the problem is our culture doesn't have
that history
and so can we import it probably not
are we going to get there from the
medical side i have my doubts
can we bootstrap something new yes but i
don't trust us to do it
yeah i think we're gonna botch it i
think we're gonna um
to the extent that we're free to do
anything we will bias towards the
recreational and frivolous and that that
is dangerous yep um
okay penultimate question why did it
evolve for humans to see beauty in
things
that are normally dangerous to human
flourishing such as a lion or a vast
desert
um that's a great question because in
general the answer is that beauty
is a heuristic for hospitableness and
value
right um i feel like we talked about the
desert thing
recently and we didn't get anywhere
maybe yeah i mean
i think it's a good question you know
i'm tempted to say exactly the kind of
thing that i scoff at when other people
say it which is oh that that sounds like
an epiphenomenon you know you have a
heuristic that that sees
beauty in a fertile valley where you
might you know
find the soil hospitable yep um and then
it sees something that it's not built
for and it
reacts positively to it but um
i don't know i don't know let's just put
it this way well i wonder
um so finding
regular lion like these are two very
different examples right
um the the abiotic thing that we find
beauty in which
cannot have a response to our finding
beauty in it
is a very different thing than the
biotic thing which could
uh evolve a way to recognize our
response to it and thus
change its behavior and response um
you know finding beauty in a lion could
be about just
awe right like recognition of the power
of that thing
um another hypothesis i think completely
untestable
uh would be that uh we came to find
wild cats more beautiful once we
domesticated
smaller cats that we could we could see
in the larger more dangerous cousins
beauty that was maybe not as
as visible to us before well
building on the first part of your
answer i'm wondering if
you know i'm thinking about why
why do we let's take something that's
not in either category
right it's not a fertile valley that
might be profitable and it's not
an dangerous thing um that is
paradoxical but what about
the beauty of a an extraordinary
uh acrobatic routine
right or some dance or something
so that's not an opportunity right
it is not a hazard it is a
recognition of how
[Music]
tightly engineered something is and
maybe the point is it's an it's an
amplitude measure of something
significance
right the desert is significant
right a desert that is you know a vast
sea of sand dunes yeah certainly not
something to be engaged casually
so focusing on it and looking at the
detail of it makes some sense
so i wonder if it's like it's an
incentive
to scrutinize before you walk into that
desert you might want to scrutinize it
right
before you go up against that challenger
you might want to see just
how in control of their weapon they
appear to be
okay okay something like that um
i don't know that's the best i got on
short notice yeah
so i changed my mind we're gonna do two
more what i know all right
with the pufferfish toxin example do you
think this could apply to humanoid
evolution on alien planets
aliens would look like us just due to
similar evolution
selection um only if that goldilocks
planet
uh that we found was really exactly the
same
not just in terms of its abiotic
parameters but had all of the same
initial conditions along every step of
the way such that the point that humans
were evolving we had the same
competitors and parasites and predators
and all this and
the abiotic stuff alone you know same
type of star emitting the same kind of
spectrum with the same gravitational
effect same size same density same math
all of this stuff um and that wouldn't
even do it
and yeah and and even then you're really
unlikely to get
there right because the scale at which
you're imagining they might look like us
the sort of sci-fi scale in which
you know the alien is kind of hot but
he's got like
a brow range or something yeah um
but uh you know first of all
how much does a deer look like a
kangaroo
a lot but not enough for
it to meet the standard of this question
right
you don't think a a deer would find a
kangaroo hot
that i can't speak to but um
[Music]
my point is you've got two creatures
that look very different and
function very differently but you know
and that's sort of the level at which
selection has reinvented a different
version on the same theme
but anyway so my point would be
that said you know look at the facial
structure of a deer
and a kangaroo there's a lot
of analogy right and in fact there are
lots of things in australia where we say
oh it's a marsupial
mouse right you know uh and the fact is
it's not
uh or you know a sugar glider and a
flying squirrel
um these things are convergently evolved
and they do have a certain similarity
but they don't look
alike in the same way that you're asking
about and so anyway my point would be
look i'd expect certain things to be
very common on other planets that are
anything like earth or maybe even not
with that caveat like
you know how organized that sends light
right organizations
uh molecules that have the capacity to
smell if you have the right receptors
right
and you know two eyes makes sense
because binocular
vision makes two centers two two ears
makes sense right because you can detect
differences in timing and
amplitude that tell you what direction
to look um the fact that all of the
sense organs are very close to the
processing organ right that makes sense
too because you don't want the messages
to take a long time to get there and
having
you know you don't want the brain
processing visual information from the
elbow
that's not good right the brain having
visual information about its immediate
environment
um is sensible so would i expect that
creatures on another planet might have a
head
yeah and that that head would be the
concentration of sense organs that
weren't about the surface of the body
yeah that we would not upon meeting them
have to be instructed as to which is the
head end
right like it would become immediately
apparent it'd be hilarious though if it
was confusing for some reason yes
right um but anyway so yes they will
look like us
very likely a creature that had the
basic um
structures you know the basic
evolutionary history similar to ours
would probably
end up looking superficially similar in
the sense of
you know organs and where they'd be and
all of that but how different could that
look
oh my god hollywood sucks at this way
more different than
well in part because it's restricted to
using ape actors
yeah ever less so
well because you've got yourself okay
yeah you've got lots of room for aliens
to look like whatever
they need to look like let's be really
union-busting
all right one more question and then i'm
going to get that hemipteran that's been
plaguing us
oh my god they really suck all right
the three people who know what i am
after in our audience are
currently laughing out loud yeah my
sister-in-law got coveted that was
barely affected and back to work in a
few days
while my brother got the vaccine i was
in bed for two days
why does covet affect people so
differently
um wait wait your brother so it's it's
not quite
the ultimate question why does covet
affect people so differently is uh one
that
i think we want we can address here but
um sister-in-law
got kovid barely affected back to work
quickly brother and
brother got the vaccine and was in bed
for two days
um you know getting the vaccine and
and getting coveted are not identical
they're not
not even close so um i have heard
anecdotal stories
of people getting very sick from the
vaccine and these are the mrna vaccines
right um that is worrisome and
independently worth
but i i do believe that all traditional
vaccines there is some
tiny number of people who do get sick
from them right but the point is
not a lot of people have had this yet
the number of
anecdotal stories of some massive fever
or anaphylactic reaction or incapacity
doesn't sound like any vaccine i'm aware
of those are very
rare cases um in general so i don't know
i have not tracked i don't want to speak
to whether or not it seems unusual at
this level
at this rate because i just don't know
what the background rate is i don't know
what the numbers are yep i agree
um as to why he's plaguing you now too
isn't it
let's talk about why people get
differently sick yeah
let's just take the simple puzzle that a
virus has to solve in order to succeed
at its mission
and its mission is to infect an
individual such that they infect other
individuals
right so it wants to get to tissues that
are capable of taking
virus that are that is output and
putting them into the world in a place
that they will get breathed in or
whatever um
so it comes in in some random place in
your
uh in your lungs let's say it infects
some
patch of which why would you mean just
where it lands right you inhale
right and you know so based on what we
said earlier
some number of these particles can get
into you and get just
regular garbage collected without any
specific interaction
with the um the adaptive immunity
system but some particle let's say gets
through this
lands in some place creates a patch of
cells that are now producing virus
well the viruses interest is in being
expelled into the world but
being expelled into the world probably
means its
primary job is to see how many tissues
it can move
into that have the potential to expel it
into the world before the immune system
gets the better of it which is the
inevitable end if you don't die from it
so the point is
an individual's illness is going to be
very idiosyncratic
where did it first get through that it
actually was able to reproduce where
could it get
from there how quickly did the immune
system get the idea
and begin to fight back at a level that
made its
job difficult and so all of these things
will be
will create a different symptomatology
yeah
your individual history the more recent
history potentially of your own immune
system
how how busy it is doing other stuff you
know have you recently been exposed also
to cold virus
or you know something else then you know
some of its capacity is busy on other
projects and
you're likely to mount a slower defense
and potentially get sicker for instance
also the fact that we have no
evolutionary history with this
particular
virus means that the immune system
doesn't necessarily know what the best
reaction is in other words a lot of your
symptoms
are actually your defenses right to the
extent
that you are fatigued and have a fever
right your fatigue may be about getting
you to lie down because there are
certain things
certain properties of your immune system
that work best or some of them only work
in that configuration
the fever is probably about creating an
environment to which the virus is not
adapted and unfortunately neither is the
rest of you so it's
uh it makes you incapacitated so
anyway the fact that our immune systems
are experimenting on reactions
might mean some of them guess right and
you don't get very sick because
they do something that hampers the virus
pretty well without interfering with you
and other things
overreact and you know throw
symptoms that aren't very effective at
defending against the pathogen
so anyway there's lots of room for
idiosync
for idiosyncratic response and there's
lots
more room based on the fact that there's
no evolutionary history here so it's not
like yet another cold virus where
you have you know the same reaction
because your body knows exactly what
it's dealing with i would say that's
that's it i think that's good and i
think that's it
i think that's it that's it that is it
all right well for this for this week
it's january 2nd
it will still be january but it will no
longer be christmas
the next time we meet wow yeah that's
totally true isn't it
yeah so um i am actually one more
question here is just a comment
remember that orthodox and greek
catholic churches celebrate christmas on
the 6th of january so that would be the
12th day if you're starting counting on
december 25th interesting yeah i did not
know these things
yeah that's uh partially because you
were not raised in any way in a
christian tradition no i was not no i
was not okay
all right so um again first against the
wall stuff is up on the store which you
see here on the screen
and you don't need the stuff to join the
club just make your piece
with what might come yeah yeah you don't
need the stuff to join the club
at all um but uh you can join
our patreons you can look at the clips
channel for
shorter versions of things you've liked
and
might have a easier time sharing than an
hour and 40 minute long conversation
um what else to say various
good stuff yeah yep um i will give
people an hour before i send out the
invites to tomorrow's evolution
discussion
we're going to make it a post right yeah
i'm going to make it a post if you were
to join your patreon anytime before 10
a.m
pacific tomorrow oh yeah actually you'd
see the post right so it doesn't
matter this is these this is the this is
the premium level these are the 250
conversation um then you could join in
and
with you for a two hour conversation
tomorrow yep all right
excellent be well everyone and we will
see you next week
[Music]
you